did you guys see this this has 26
million views so yes you've seen it but
let's talk about this for a second this
is the real life
Liam Neeson I love this video
it's dash cam footage of a cash van crew
under attack from robbers okay this is
like the [__] where you're like
does this really though does it really
happen like this is the real life Liam
Neeson here I think this is South Africa
the real life Liam Neeson
and did this there's two dudes there's a
white older dude which is if this was
the movie it would be the real life Liam
Neeson and then there's the younger
black dude
and and it was literally the fir the
guy's like first drive
or or first week in working and and this
would the guy who is playing this
younger black male would be
like the and introducing
an actor you know what I mean it'd be
like Liam Neeson and also there's this
guy
that we're introducing
just so you know we're woke
and it would be like some [__] movie
but the the way they deal with it is
awesome
they're driving they're just driving
they're driving that money van dude
and I think a minute in
let me go to a minute in
it's a normal day dude
looking at his side mirror
I don't know if you notice if
something's up yet
side mirror
car passes
a minute five in the video there it is
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
guy goes
swerves swerves [__] fill that
to the rookie rookie says nothing
I know
for a fact
I know for a fact
if I was in the you know people like
well you don't know how you'd react
if I wasn't driving
if I was in the passenger seat
and that happened to me
for a fact I'm not trying to be funny
this is what I would be saying okay okay
okay okay okay okay that's what I would
be saying
that's pretty [__]
but I would be saying it calmly like
okay okay okay okay I'd be like Joe
Pesci and Lethal Weapon for okay okay
okay okay okay that would be me all
right
you got your gun he says
and the rookie picks up the small gun he
goes this one it gives them the [__]
the one that like you can't even hold in
a
in a car he's like this and it's [__]
sticking up he can't stick it under his
arm because then he'll literally be you
can't open the windows because they're
designed like that because they're
bulletproof and you're not supposed to
open the window so they can't even open
the window and fire out of it they have
to open the door and fire out of it
which is something that I know because
I'm smart
and you didn't know that because you're
[__] stupid sorry I I I I sometimes I
hate telling you the truth
swerving again
because he almost hit a [__] car that
stopped
boom hits a car
you know why he hits a car because it's
because it's crazy right now that's why
that's all I can say because it's [__]
swerving all over the place shot out the
tire I found out later the tire was shot
out Liam Neeson kept driving and
introducing young actor still holding
the gun up like that it's pointed to his
thigh you know because the guy can't
stick it out the window and he's calm as
[__] dude they're both
killing it
I would have said okay 47 times so far
no [__] that I would have called
everybody up my mom my fiance put
FaceTime hey guys sorry we're getting
shot at I just want to pass the phone to
pass the phone to Mom Dad pass the phone
to Mom Dad Dad it's face time so you
don't have all I see is your ear pass it
pass it to Mom Dad just look at the
camera God damn it
you're on fate then my mom like this can
you hold it up a little bit so you don't
look like Jabba the Hutt please
it's back I just see what your mom I
could just see Rachel Maddow on the TV
hit it so it [__] flips back your way
now they're in a park dude they pull off
bro the end of this
I'm gonna skip forward to the end of it
they're trying to call
they're [__] people to get back up
they can't do it because the crooks the
robbers
they have S [__] cell phone
scramblers like this is real [__]
they're getting scrambled I can't I
can't do it I can't do it
guns still
can't do it but just so you know if
if my thighs acts up I can get I can
take them out
I can take my thigh out right now if you
think my thigh is one of the bad guys I
just click it and it it's we got it
the guy's just
like he's looking for someone at a party
they stop at a park
Tire's gone crash into the robbers
can't reverse
I read about this so that's why I know
even though it's just showing the desk
but Robert ran away guy gets out of the
car runs after him with his [__]
ak-47.
lost him
how different is that guy than you
that is insane dude those [__]
kept calm
and carried on